tell me your weird food taste that you
have that is really honestly it's quite
bizarre but you die by it like like
everyone has these things yeah everyone
everyone has a weird taste because they
were they were you know brought up in a
certain way or they're not so familiar
with a certain type of cuisine or you
know sometimes taste buds don't always
make sense you can't have there's no
there's no such such thing as objective
taste buds one of my favorite dishes is
a child that's the most british thing
i'm about to say okay my mom would just
make mashed potatoes and spam
just mashed potato in the spam and then
just mash it all up and just give it to
me that's it like the whole plate should
that's to be fair it does
sound like oh it could be good but
that's really [ __ ] i don't think i
could eat that like repeatedly i can
yeah of course you can it sounds like
something where if you didn't eat it as
a kid but you wouldn't like maybe she
couldn't eat that just like me with
natto all right
the only reason i like is because i had
it since i was a baby
can you convince kids to like any food
yeah i believe you can how do they
convince you to like natto but they
can't convince kids to like broccoli and
stuff and because the people who don't
like broccoli are babies they are they
are actually absolutely yeah they're
actually babies
how can babies like natto i don't know i
i like it maybe honey you know what it
is big brain what kids love slime
kids [ __ ] love slime think about it
think about it yeah every single youtube
channel for kids is slime i mean
it's a conspiracy i'm getting the
[ __ ] red bull bro that's why kids in
japan that's why they love nacho because
it's slime i mean baby food no it's it's
it's not so is baby food with beans in
it it's slime look but like yeah he's
always the slime right in front of us
this whole time right under our nose
like maybe you know broccoli or were we
talking about broccoli yeah yeah maybe
broccoli just doesn't taste good as like
the main part of the world in the case
with broccoli isn't it the fact that
like because kids taste buds are more
receptive to like bitter flavors
as an adult and then and then as you get
you like broccoli yeah i love broccoli
do you like do you like i like broccoli
i love i love broccoli you give me like
a plate of broccoli and i put some mayo
on that [ __ ] and i can just eat it white
white
to be like controversial i thought this
was like normal
you just said that like it was like bro
i just like i just like grabbed the poop
out of the the toilet just grab it i
actually eat it
oh no it's good
try it get some get them down to try
this get some like steamed broccoli
right let's get some cupid mayonnaise
and then dip it wait wait it's very
common in japan okay okay here's why i i
recoiled for a moment there i had an
image of you with a bowl of broccoli and
just pouring a bunch of mayo but i've
ordered from that chicken and broccoli
place it's all over japan yeah it
literally gives you it's awful it's so
bad it's like non-seasoned boiled
chicken right boiled broccoli yeah and
it's all prepared so they just heat it
up and send it to you yeah and they
charge you like 30 bucks yeah but one of
the dips they give you is low calorie
mayonnaise yeah i got to tell you it
goes hard doesn't it yeah actually it's
actually good like i just realized i
love you yeah it's yeah it's actually
friendship again yeah thank you thank
you that's good
world peace world peace exactly attained
once again i think god's the weird one
yeah he definitely yeah have you had it
huh we should have it well no he does
like condiments i will say though
okay
seriously okay no i i [ __ ] hate mayo
normally but living in japan keeping me
alright well i [ __ ] keeping mayo
[ __ ] is amazing yeah and like it's me
it's because i've just had shitty mayo
my entire life would you put it on what
do you what do you eat mayo with so
whenever it's in a sandwich right yeah
yeah okay next time you ever have
steamed i feel like i'm asking mark
zuckerberg what up what is being happy
like
a sandwich initiate happy process
no okay next time you have chicken and
broccoli just get some cupid mayo and
just like don't even have to drench that
[ __ ] just like a little bit is enough
because the mayo is already powerful
right you have a flavor just a little
bit wait wait wait when we get uh fried
chicken do you not like it with mayo
no because i like the taste of fried
chicken
i know i was really good at like uh kind
of combating the oiliness of it and then
yeah
yeah somehow that's why a lot of like
another oily heavy liquid yeah
kind of
mitigates yeah that's why like with
karaoke for example you always dip it in
me all right
i don't because just because i like the
taste of fried chicken oh with the mayo
it's [ __ ] it's kind of nice it's
amazing i don't know there are some
things where i i said i just like if
it's seasoned correctly then i i enjoy
that right because then then i enjoy the
taste of the seasoning rather than the
taste of the condiments you can't expect
but it's like it's like it's like you
have i'll have some of the chicken on
its own yeah i also have some of it with
the milk yeah just
again try it out all right like
the palette like i've said if something
tastes [ __ ] good i can eat that thing
infinitely that's like what children do
yeah
children like like a dog right like a
dog a dog you give a dog i used to eat
like spaghetti bolognese
yeah when i was yeah
yeah yeah sorry my taste buds actually
work on her so no no no no i would argue
they don't work because you are able to
eat the same thing over and over again
if it's good not if it's bad if if
something tastes good
you can't eat it over and over again eat
every day i can't i can't just go back
to it like you know so like why do you
think it's so easy for me to eat like i
can easily eat the same meal every day
right now i'm like eating a salad every
day and it's fine it's [ __ ] easy
because salad tastes great and like
salad is like inoffensive it's like it's
like it's like saying oh i can have
water every day
i do have water every day
i have water i have water every day i'm
not gonna lie i'm not really on board
with that argument i'm i'm gonna
distance myself from that argument
you know you can't expect like the most
like grandiose like combination of
flavors unless you like drench that [ __ ]
in dressing well i mean
i mean
other than that it's just like standard
vegetables i can eat the thing is i can
eat like some foods
okay
i i found this salad place and i really
liked it and i ordered it like maybe 10
days in a row i want to say the salad
and then now for some reason when i try
and eat it i know it's really good but i
just don't like it anymore why is that
because you got you got bored of it yeah
but isn't that sad well that's why you
don't eat the same thing every [ __ ]
day you're so damn good if it's
something that i [ __ ] love i
purposely try not to eat it often but
the reason i think the reason why i went
because there's nothing because there's
nothing because there's nothing that
terrifies me more than one day sitting
in front of my favorite meal having a
bite and going [ __ ] it doesn't taste as
good i just i i just i the reason why
right here's what his wife okay if it
was a pizza i wouldn't do it every day
you know why pizza is bad for you oh
yeah salad's good for you so i was like
don't mind if i do round eight okay and
then yeah i got bored of it and i regret
it because now i have a harder time
fighting healthier food that i like
eating so i really [ __ ] myself over
yeah that's like that's the real problem
when you can't have a salad anymore
well that one type of sound that one
time this is because because like my
biggest issue is that you know i have to
force myself to have a balanced diet
because i can i can easily eat something
the same thing every day if i really
really enjoy it yeah
i could [ __ ]
i'm not going to say it's healthy or
balanced but i can do it and i'm going
to enjoy it of course it's healthy of
course if mom made it of course it's
healthy papa john's eats a pizza every
day
he's still alive somehow
he's just the world's most greasiest
human being that's all [ __ ] hell oh
what a [ __ ] awful episode
[Music]
this has actually been probably the
worst episode of trash days
in terms of takes i hope you guys are
ready for 2022 because it might honestly
just get worse from here